[Music]
is it fearful time in American life
obviously Americans worried they could
die of this disease that someone they
love could die that they might lose
their jobs at the country that they grew
up in could be crippled permanently in
the wake of this disaster it's a
terrifying moment and in that moment we
need wisdom and steady guidance from our
leaders we need altruism they need to
care more about you than they care about
themselves but in Congress they don't
the foremost concern of some members is
saving their own investment portfolios
or making stupid partisan points or
indulging their creepy ideological
obsessions wondering why Congress hasn't
yet passed a bill to help the country
survive this
that's why details of the Democratic
plan became public today huge parts that
proposal have nothing to do with
fighting the pandemic we're suffering
through read it and you will find
disgusting little interest group
handouts added by lobbyists worse the
bill is suffused with the cruel bigotry
of identity politics at a time when
America's so badly desperately needs to
come together Democrats remain intent on
splitting this country into warring
tribes it's shocking when asked about
her bill today Nancy Pelosi blamed the
Pope last Thursday Pope Francis offered
the world this prayer enlighten those
responsible for the common good so that
they might know how to care for those
entrusted to their responsibilities
today House Democrats are unveiling that
take responsibility for workers and
Families Act a bill that takes
responsibility for the health wages and
well-being of America's workers the
Senate Republican bill put corporations
first but because of the insistence of
Leader Chuck Schumer and Senate
Democrats progress has been made even by
Washington standards shamelessness like
that really has no precedent quoting the
Pope st. Nancy's coronavirus bill
currently is more than 1400 pages it's
not that long because it's a
finely-tuned fix to help the country
through his disasters no it's that long
because House Democrats have crammed it
with totally unrelated political
priorities identity Paula
tics stoking racial division as usual
global warming open borders you should
read it here's just some of what you'll
find if you do the bill would require
every corporation that receives
coronavirus aid to have officers any
budget dedicated to diversity and
inclusion initiatives for a minimum of
five years after they get the money
because that is going to keep America
healthy and prosperous just like it has
more bean counters making sure you're
the right color before they give you a
job okay companies would also have to
produce elaborate racial reports for the
government listing the skin color and
the sex of their officers and boards of
directors they have to prove they give
enough money to firms owned by women and
non-whites and of course how much they
spent on diversity initiatives in all
this bill uses the words diverse or
diversity more than 60 times what does
it have to do with the pandemic that
might kill you
not one thing just more ugly race
politics the kind they specialize in
Democrats think that's much more
important right now and then it gets
worse than that the bill allocates 300
million dollars for hiring experts to
manage coronavirus preparation and
response those are critical jobs but
instead of looking for the most
qualified people in a time of national
emergency and that's the only criterion
that should matter in the least right
now period are you qualified instead of
that the bill orders that employees be
chosen on the basis of their race and
disability status this is insanity it's
dangerous insanity
who cares what color your scientists are
but it goes on they would mandate that
all 50 states have an early voter period
as well as same-day voter registration
why because Democrats believe those
changes would give them an electoral
advantage the bill would expand
collective bargaining rights for federal
employees that's likely the group least
threatened by the effect of coronavirus
but and this is the real point though
they're the most faithful democratic
voting bloc so there in the bill on
matters of policy the bill doesn't even
try should the airlines get a federal
bailout that's an actual question you
could take either side Democrats don't
lead well on it in this bill it's too
serious for them instead the law would
require that any airline that takes
federal money offset their carbon
emissions within five years because
climate activism is way more important
the disease that could kill your family
next we
and then there's this the House version
the bill includes special provisions for
real to protect foreign nationals
working here in the US so we're staring
down the barrel of the most profound
employment crisis of our lifetimes
that's not an exaggeration
and what are Democrats doing they're
trying to automatically renew visas and
work permits for all immigrants here in
the US because their jobs are very
important way more important than yours
Democrats want to make certain the
people who are replacing you are secure
and happy the whole thing defies belief
and that's not a partisan observation
again read it Republican version of the
bill is not that awful nothing could be
that awful but we want to be fair and
tell you everything that's going on
tonight on Capitol Hill and according to
an informed source that we spoke to some
Senate Republicans are trying to kill
the requirement the companies that
receive bailout funds stop sending
American jobs overseas why would they do
something like that
we don't know you'd have to ask the
business groups like the Chamber of
Commerce that are funding them